we got gta 5 on the ps5 and decided it
would be cool to compare how the game
looks compared to one of its first
platforms over nine years ago the ps3 in
case you were dying to know the ps5 is
running on 30 fps fidelity mode in 4k
the ps3
well it's a ps3
it's trying very hard like this vid sub
to the channel and enjoy
i don't even think about it
i'll do it
oh god get in there
sit tight i'll handle the plastic don't
blow yourself up
pay attention what's he doing
he's gonna
get these [ __ ] in the closet
in the back come on
[Music]
all set phone it in
i'm making the call
[Music]
all right i'm gonna do this
show me the money
slow and steady t slow and steady
oh
there it is
there's enough here for us all to enjoy
depends on how you look at it
what's the holdup
coming out me
what took you so long shut the [ __ ] up
and drive
did you see that [ __ ]
with that bitch's face against the glass
did you see that yeah you're a real
stout
[Music]
come on let's get to the chopper
we move quick we can beat the train
we're getting there
cops coming our way be cool they ain't
made this car yet
man i'll believe in this bird when i get
eyes on it
[ __ ] [ __ ] dick roadblock go right beat
the train man
someone have [ __ ] talked
all right brad's gonna be fine we gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here
go ahead
oh jesus
key you gotta get out of here i'm gonna
leave you my cake go
god i'm not gonna be
[ __ ] gonna bleed out
[Music]
no
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i'm standing here finish me
i'll [ __ ] die all of you
you're [ __ ] with
die me got suckers
you [ __ ] [ __ ] suckers
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] stay back you come here
go
your son james
he's a good kid
he's a good kid
a good kid
why
does he help the [ __ ] poor
no
he sits on his ass all day
smoking dope and jerking off while he
plays that [ __ ] game
if that's our standard for goodness no
wonder this country's screwed
and what about you
what about me
hey
i don't have the advantages that kid has
by the time i was his age i'd already
been in prison twice
i robbed banks i ran [ __ ] smuggled
dope and you consider them achievements
these were the opportunities i had at
least i took them and where did these
opportunities get you michael
they got me right
[ __ ] here
the end of the road
with a big house and a useless kid and
i'm stuck talking to you because no one
else gives a [ __ ] oh i'm living the
dream baby and that dream is [ __ ] it
is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let it all out
i think i just did
oh
well i
think that's all we have time for
the same time next week
right up here homie i'm about to go nice
and slow for your [ __ ]
[Music]
hey remember we got to be careful with
these rides homie but simeon ain't about
to dock my play again homie man if you
need some bread i could hook you up with
jb's tow truck it ain't got glamour but
it's some money to be made so him and
tanya can smoke cracking peace
i'm good
if you want to get whips like this you
got to stay on your gridiron they can't
do some time over nickels and dimes i
stick to repose dog
handle right there
what i hear you
[Applause]
right homie fine
let's show these movie people how we
roll
nazi you are all the same
this racist insulted me hey what's up
whoa who are you calling
no no i'm not calling nobody in wait
what the [ __ ] i i mean
n word i i that that's not cool man i
don't say that you're [ __ ] right and
you better keep it right cause this man
right here he's an international
businessman a multiculturalist that i
could not have said better myself ah
but seriously maybe he's not a racist
but i don't think that he is man enough
for a car like this
wait a second
this guy right here him
get him a hybrid that's a real man's car
i think you are right lamar you get a
tax rebate i understand money is an
issue
money isn't an issue this is the best
part watch this when he really mean he
gonna get all his full money what's this
look man i gotta go
hey samia
i'm out
i holler at you homie it's the best part
[Music]